[Music]
our entire medical system really relies
on antibiotics
this would be the biggest health crisis
that we've experienced this century
we don't hear about it but it's already
here
nobody is safe
until we're all safe
what would a world without antibiotics
look like
well i think it would look a lot like
the past where a lot of people would die
younger than they do now
just think about
war more people died of infections and
their wounds
than died actually on the battlefield
[Music]
here man has locked his heaviest
artillery against premature death
antibiotics the discovery of various
classes of antibiotics in the 20th
century had a profound impact on
healthcare so treatment of infection
suddenly became very straightforward and
it's something that we benefit a lot
from today
antibiotics protect people during
operative surgery cesarean sections
replacement joints let alone cancer
treatments antibiotics added on average
20 years life to everyone
[Music]
i went to the hospital the emergency
room
they said they gave them a broad
spectrum antibiotics then they took me
to another room and they're like
your son has an infection we don't know
the source
we were in the icu with like 10 doctors
and they said
he
wasn't really going to make it
at that point i knew that he was dead i
could feel it and that's when
we learned that simon had contracted an
antibiotic resistant bacterium a
superbug
and i had never heard of any of this
use penicillin today an english
physician dr alexander fleming alexander
fleming's discovery of penicillin was
immense
noticing that in a petri dish where
bacteria were growing there were white
areas where
the bacteria were not growing and he
realized that something had happened he
looked and found the fungus
penicillin
our first effective antibiotic that
saved masses of lives
most antibiotics come from soil and
fungi
[Music]
when i expose bacteria to antibiotics
they're going to become resistant which
is very bad because we haven't
discovered a new antibiotic in like the
last 30 years
[Music]
growing up back in mexico you didn't
need a prescription to get an antibiotic
you had a little bit of a sore throat
you go to the pharmacy and get an
antibiotic and that only gives more and
more chances to these bugs to acquire
mutations to become resistant
[Music]
the time may come when penicillin can be
bought by anyone in the shops
then there is a danger that the ignorant
man may easily underdose himself and by
exposing his microbes to the non-lethal
quantities of the drug makes them
resistant
the situation
today is more serious than people
realize
it's actually the first real study
looking at all the data 494 million
patient records to model
what is happening
[Music]
it is predicted that by
2050 10 million people are going to die
every year
from complications with superbugs
resistant microbes so we really have to
find alternative strategies to find
against these bugs
a world without antibiotics i sometimes
call it the post
apocalypse would impact on our food
chain too because animals would get ill
plants would get ill and die
we would really be in the most dreadful
mess
as an individual i think one of the most
important things is don't ask for
antibiotics if they're not offered to
you if you are prescribed antibiotics
then make sure you finish the course of
antibiotics that you're given because if
you don't finish the course even if
you're feeling better there might be
some residual infection that could
become resistant
we have
probably found the easy to find
antibiotics but that doesn't mean there
are not many more to be found
if we keep recycling the same old
treatments then the problem is just
going to exacerbate
one of the main bottlenecks with
antibiotic research
is
that the easiest thing to do is to look
at the structures of existing
antibiotics and modify those slightly to
try to overcome the resistance it's much
more challenging to find a completely
new class of antibiotics so we have to
fund quite widely in order to be able to
identify those strategies that are going
to work best
i think if there were more awareness
then there would be more general
pressure
from society on governments and on
companies to fund more research into
targeting this problem we should be
anticipating problems and doing
something about them before they become
enormous global crises
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video
you